[Music]
is the hijab 10
discount code for 10 discount on a wide
range of products including
premium ethiopian black seed products
what i'm saying to you is that morally
speaking yeah
as an atheist you have no anchorage
meaning you cannot claim anything is
objective
otherwise i'll say to you look give me
your mechanism because you're on the
record of saying that bestiality is okay
you're on the record saying that father
can have sex with his son i have never
said that
oh so you don't agree with that incest
is okay you said incest okay no i have
never said that either
so if two sisters or two brothers have
incest sexual relationship there's
nothing i can't see anything wrong with
it right well there is
uh actually nothing wrong with it here
actually nothing wrong with it here
look do you believe this do you believe
it is the case or not i have said
i've said to alegawa he asked me do you
think it's okay for the father and the
son to have sex
yeah if there was no harm to society
[Music]
yeah so you allow it
hey shut up i said if the evidence was
so hard
yeah so there you have it bro
so here's the problem why are you using
the harm principle but why are you using
the harm principle
but that is not reality but why are you
using the hum principle because such a
intercourse will have
harm on the individuals and the society
which is why
can you prove the harm principle can you
objectively prove the harm principle
no no i'm asking you right now you said
something you made a claim so can you
prove it
you asked me to prove things i've
answered you can you can you objectively
prove the hum principle
you cannot that's the answer that you
cannot it's not that you will not is
that you cannot
i can't i will no you can't because john
stuart milk couldn't
john stewart mill couldn't do it look
let's not pretend to be a philosopher i
do not believe that there is an
intrinsic uh sorry sorry you don't
believe objective
i don't believe that there is inherent
objective that doesn't make sense
objective morality you don't believe in
objection rally
yeah i do and i've got the degrees to
show it have you have you got anything
to show
on a descriptive level
in which you prescribe it to society i
do not believe that intrinsically
there is objective morality
no that doesn't make sense what you're
saying doesn't make sense no your
articulation is flawed your articulation
is slowed
your articulation is flawed now do you
know why because what you're saying is
i do not believe when a human being has
morality is not possessive in that sense
you're you're all over the place you
either believe in honor
you either believe in objective morality
or you don't you're either subjectivist
or an objectivist which one of the two
are you
are you subjectivist or objectivist
let me say it in different words no
because you don't understand english as
a first language i do
so don't try it don't try it you didn't
make sense in your articulation now
you're trying to make me look like the
person no your articulation was flawed
so now say in a proper way go on
i would like to say there is a
difference between saying a society
has intrinsic morality and a difference
between a society
a society should have more health what
about society what society got to do
with it
are do morals exist as an objective
reality or not
yeah really so there's something that's
called more realism what's our morals
are
our morals objectively real or not are
they real or not are they are
morals objective or they're subjective
so what are they are they objective or
subjective
in your view
okay my my question to you is so simple
like my question to you
is morality is it objective
or not are there such a thing as
objective moral
i don't think so okay good so so then
there all of your moral arguments have
collapsed against islam so today we've
collapsed all your scientific ones
and we've collapsed all your moral ones
yeah because
anything that you say about islam now
now hold on anything that you say about
islam now morally
doesn't make sense because there's no
such thing as morality objectively
this is how morality works you just said
it yourself you don't believe it's
objective it's not true it's not
objectively
nihilism is not synonymous with
objectivity
right what are you talking about yeah
i'm saying that they're not subjective
it's not synonymous nihilism is
something which is
yeah good good so you're saying you're a
subjectivist if you're a subjectivist
that you said you're not an objectivist
you must be a subjectivist what are you
doing
stop pretending you stop pretending i'm
the idiot bro i've studied this you have
not
did you just say if i'm not an
objectivist you have to be
if you're not if you don't believe in
objective morality what are you laughing
at man
so if i don't believe in objective
morality then i have to believe in
subjectivity yeah because either
objective or subjective you've got two
choices
what what's the third option go on bro
you're not even on a levels level
bro i swear to god
you're not even a c grade a level you're
not even a secret
if i were to if i were to mark your work
bro you're not on c grades
you're not on bro at year 10 year 11
in ethics can get a better understanding
of what i'm saying a 16 year old a sharp
16 year old will see that you don't know
what you're talking about
now what is the other option you've got
objective morality subjective money
what's the third one
now go and say it what's the third
option you've i've got look you're
talking but you have no answers
you've either got objective morality
subjective money what's the other one
what's the other one do you think do you
think there is no other option
yeah yeah i'm saying there's only it's
either objective or subjective is what's
the third one
yeah come on what's the third one
what are you laughing at that's not an
answer bro i will make a video
responsibility
no you don't need to make a video
response if it's not objective it has to
be subjective
bro you're going to get laughed at you
know cosmic skeptic and dumb guys
they're going to laugh at you bro
they're going to say we're going to
disassociate with this idiot of all due
respect
you have not even an a level
understanding of morality it's either
objective or not it's either objective
or not
if it's not objective it has to be
subjective there's no other option what
can it be
there's no crossover there's no middle
ground it's either objective or not
you that that's the that's why why you
got it all wrong that's why your
criticisms against islam
are flawed because you don't even have a
basic understanding of moral flaws you
don't
and you can't pretend you do you have
not done a levels even in there
bro you don't know it you have no
qualifications stop condescending us
man you don't know it i'm saying i'm
saying to all those viewers
i would like to say including you what
moment did you have said about
objective morality is for example
completely wrong go on give me the third
option
if i don't if i don't believe in
objective morality for example yeah
yes that doesn't mean that i cannot have
objective values
i'm not saying that i'm saying you
either believe in objective morality or
you believe in subjective money there's
no third option what's the third option
what's the offered option what is the
third option stop laughing stop
pretending you know what you're talking
about and give a third option
i swear to god you are finished in a way
that you don't even know
bro people are going to be laughing at
you atheists are going to say we thought
we had hope in this guy
the great hope of uh anti-islamic
polemics has just fumbled
bro it's either objective or subjective
there's no third option what is the
third option
what's the third option what's the third
option
that are not based on the belief um look
that's a different discussion you either
believe in objective morality or
subjective military you're saying
there's a third option what is the third
option
because you know there is no third
option you will not say it because there
is no answer
look look make a video make a video mate
because you're gonna you're embarrassing
yourself with what you respect if it's
not objective look
let me teach you let me allow me to
teach you allow me
you know just allow it just allow it
just submit to the knowledge submit to
the truth
submit to the knowledge allow it what
i'm saying to you is this
whether there are only two pardons i was
the one who asked you yeah i said it's
either objective or subjective what you
got the third what's the third one right
we're done we're done i answer this
question
yeah yeah yeah okay well i'm asking you
also further option if it's not
objective it has to be subjective i will
not respond to you
why don't you answer the video no
because he's laughing because he's
nervous he's nervous because he's got no
answers in his empty head that's the
reason why
bro look you don't you're having look
we're having a discussion now and you're
not really producing substance you
haven't shown your you haven't shown
your abilities to be honest
you're playing by yourself whatever man
this is philosophy look if if
you look man you're gonna try and weasel
away from this and scramble
you really have nothing to say do you
you really have nothing to say because
here's the thing
we talked about the science and we
realized that all your scientific
arguments are flawed
you pretty much admitted that then now
we're going to morality and we realize
that
you know what if you don't believe in if
you don't sorry which you've said you
said you don't believe in
objective morality if you don't believe
in objective morality which means this
means any listen this is you know what
the implication is the implication is
this
the implication is any argument you get
make against islam which is moral
if you're asking about uh age of consent
or apostasy or
a penal laws or anything you want to ask
from this
day onwards you have no right to say it
that well that's why you can't prove
your morality you can't prove it
you're asking us to prove god i'm asking
you to prove your morality
is completely based on utilitarianism
yeah but
john stuart mill and bentham jeremy
bentham who is the who's the founding
father
of utilitarianism they these individuals
never said that it was objective
it doesn't depend on individuals that's
not how it works yes it does because
utilitarianism is based on jeremy
benfield's ethic
that it has to utilitarianism by wait a
minute who who who made the idea of you
who is who is the philosophical founding
father of utilitarianism
let me teach you my man who who who put
forward utilitarianism
let me educate you you can't because i'm
telling you who is the founding father
of utilitarianism you can't even answer
that
who is it have you read jeremy bentham's
books
one more question have you read it have
you read it honestly have you read it
have you read it who is jeremy benson
who is jeremy bentham who is jeremy
bentham who is jeremy bentham who is he
who is jeremy bentham who is he is what
you're saying you don't know
it's what you're saying that if you
abide by a moral philosophy you have to
agree with what one certain person
who founded the philosophy no i've not
said that what i'm saying is this
that no no hold on the definition of
what's the definition of utilitarianism
what's the definition of
i can't utilitarianism a utilitarian
point of view what is the definition of
utility i'll ask you a basic question
man
what's the definition of utilitarianism
the great is good for the greatest
number
this guy you haven't studied this don't
pretend please decide
to decide that something is better for
society for which they come as a result
of the common consensus or due to new
findings
then it means that this will be a law
that society has agreed on
and this is utilitarian no it's not
really that's not that's not a
definition of utilitarianism
utilitarianism is not defined like that
by any moral or political philosopher
by the way just i've written essays on
italianitarianism i've written by the
way i've got some of something written
on utilitarianism as well
it's called the problem of liberalism
and you can find that on for free
muhammad hijab put it on google
problems of liberal liberalism and you
can find it for free i've written about
the stuff you claim to talk about i've
written about it bro
i've published essays on it no
what i'm trying to tell you is don't
pretend to arrogate to me you're not a
professor you're not my
senior do you get it if you're my senior
you could talk like that you're not like
just go yeah you look look at this box
yeah read my books bro look
can i can i just come back on this adam
adam one thing one one thing on this
yeah
or can i just please please please
please just allow me just for a second
yeah
utilitarianism no no just give me a
second give me a second let me just get
you yeah let me educate you let me share
my knowledge with you in there what's
wrong you educate me from your little
no knowledge from your google searches
let me educate you of formal knowledge
let me tell you what's going on
utilitarianism yeah well it's really if
you want to put it in a nutshell is the
greatest good for the greatest number
the greatest utility for the greatest
amount of people
now obviously no just allow me just
allow me just allow me just please
no you you know listen hold on for a
second hold on you didn't you used
democratic logic it's different what i'm
saying is this is you
what what jeremy ben from in his book
said wait listen what generally benfica
in his book he said he said it's very
it's interesting because there's a
quranic argument against this it's
really interesting
he said you've got two lords you've got
the lord of pain and you've got the lord
of pleasure
what the quran says have you seen the
one who has taken his own
desires as a god so it's interesting the
quran has actually addressed
utilitarianism in a in
an interesting kind of way now the thing
is what john stuart mill said
is that say if you have a gang greg gang
rape scenario yeah
this is a common analogy that's put
forward you've got a gang rape scenario
so you've got one woman
and then you've got five men and they're
all having their goals with her and
she's not wanting it she's
she's getting raped yeah she got
finished now in this situation
is this good now obviously according to
utilitarianism in a strict sense
it's allowed because obviously there's
no harm principle in place so john
stuart mill said look
in order to allow society to function we
have to put a harm principle in place
so that's how utilitarianism kind of was
absorbed into social liberalism
yeah now with social liberalism here's
my point
uh john stuart mill who really was a
utilitarian at heart and by the way his
father james mill
was jeremy bentham's friend they were
their buddies yeah that like this guy
who wrote
about utilitarianism his father james
mill were friends now he wrote a book
now in that book he said in
on utilitarianism the name of the book
on chapter four
yeah he talked about proving
utilitarianism now he didn't mention he
didn't name it like that
he named it a long thing as cosmic
accepted tommy in a debate but anyway he
took like a long um
title but it's candid in there he talks
about desirability yeah
he doesn't in any way shape or form try
and say that
utilitarianism is in any way an
objective morality this is the problem
what i'm saying is you're saying that
you you can have objective morality
through utilitarianism
but jeremy bentham and john stuart mill
who were the philosopher
philosophical founding fathers they
candidly said you can't really have that
kind of thing
it's more to do with it it's not meant
to be an objective morality in that
sense
so in other words if you're you if
you're pegging your moral value
judgments on utilitarianism
you can't go and attack the quran
because you know why you don't have an
anchorage you don't have an objective
morality
so you come back to the quran and say
the quran says this and that you can't
say
based on utilitarianism because even
according to those guys and
all the way through to today's
scholarship i'm telling you i've read
the journals bro
i have read the journals people that are
bigger than me and you look utilitarian
scholars
i've read the journals i've read the
books i've done the research i've done
the degrees please
don't don't don't arrogate to me yeah
i've read all no one no one is making
the argument
it's it's it's it's not an argument that
utilitarian liberal ethical scholars say
that actually utilitarianism is an
objective morality it's not
they know it's not wonderful
it's not it's not an argument therefore
if you want to make a moral argument
against islam and say well islam is
against this
and therefore islam is wrong it's a
false argument if you're basing on
utilitarianism that's your seed bed if
that's your intellectual and
epistemological seedbed it's not going
to work so what i'm saying is that now
since you've since science has crumbled
and since morality
has crumbled what have you got left to
try and no it has no what you're
laughing at man what's funny i don't get
it
since your since your scientific
arguments have crumbled and now
the philosophical thing has crumbled my
question is what you got left what you
got left for us where you go left first
honestly
it's not you i've look i'm not here to
destroy you you're not worthy of me
destroying you
you're not worthy of me destroying you
i'm just destroying your arguments your
weak
arguments that you don't even know yeah
i know the shame
the shame of the matter is this the
shame is i know my scriptures
and my worldview more than you do but i
know your scriptures and your worldview
more than you do
that's that's the shame here
have you got anything have you got
anything left have you got anything left
if you want to make islam you just have
to respond to people and share your
opinion
bro you look bewildered to avoid your
respect you looked you disappointed me i
have to be honest i thought you're going
to come swinging
you know it's like you know what it is
adam and er slim bro i'll be honest with
you i thought this guy had packed a
punch
i thought he had packed the punch a
little bit because he was coming rough
on twitter he was coming tough on
twitter he was
ripping up the quran this guy was eating
the quran his friend was
he was laughing i thought this guy was
going to swing us off
and finish us but you know what's
happened today all of his arguments have
collapsed
bro i have to say this with all due
respect you are finished you know you
are finished
you have been finished
you're finished bro you've tried your
best for two hours don't pretend this
wasn't a debate
it was a debate and it's done bro it's
finished with all due respect
you've got nothing you've got nothing
you're gonna be disowned now by the
atheist
your liability to atheists with your low
knowledge
you